whoa we have a game between our houses
one hit kills anywhere below I kind of
where the tattoo is
um yeah and you baby
I maybe got it cuz that's gonna it up my
god yeah I'm like champ so we're making
some janky WWE turnbuckles things in the
corners of a wrestling ring that hold
the ropes together cord or digital it's
always a learning experience
showed me 34 probably got a pen - a pen
on it lawyer - prop builder let's do
this this should come off yeah this is
big guy okay I gotta get this off so
that I can put it on this so like we
just need some good old-fashioned
American elbow grease maybe kids don't
do this about your parents rep
interesting predicament yeah
plan a unsuccessful problems not with my
eyes Nick I guess we'll just use a giant
drill bit ship auger I split it
oh that bouncy house no you're on the
5.8 gigahertz channel right oh hi pointy
that's a lot of gigahertz just how Brep
anikó gonna look like in the future
they come over something some ways to
make it less nauseating it's not very
nauseating
we're gonna do a dogfight video okay
yeah well let me introduce you to a
couple of guys that drill some more
holes Steel's would we have accumulated
a lot of this over time he's ready to
carry the cross we all have our own
cross to bear just pull straight down
yeah just look away look away look away
look away I'm moving it see if she
stands this is so janky
yeah there's King buggers I'm moving
like I'm doing something I get the V R
or something holy
it's your way if I wanted to have one
guy from the corridor to go total
divided hey they may be a pleasure for
you
they'd like to know what you'd shoot and
stuff there I'm sure we can find some
things to shoot I would need help
shooting if it's possible to have two of
us go uh I can ask like over the train
station stop that stop that other stuff
so it's about 7:00 in the morning and I
just got official news that we are
indeed going to Dubai Wow it's actually
happening I guess I should start picking